bonjour tout le monde alors aujourd'hui
c'est une vidéo qui va venir en fait en
complément d'un article que j'ai écrit
sur chercher ce point comme et donc
l'article c'était un peu pour expliquer
comment enfin quelle méthodologie au
fait avoir je pense pour se construire
un répertoire d'ouvertures ou donc
j'explique il faut pas bêtement à
prendre la théorie est copié depuis de
trouver une idée une variante une
ouverture qui vous plaît alors ça ça
peut être de différentes manières par
exemple c'est une ouverture qu'un joueur
vous avez bien jouent ou à vous avez une
partie de vous avez vu une partie
spectaculaire et vous dit à ben ok c'est
cool tu tiens je voudrais bien joué ça
et donc à partir cette idée là comment
commandes à prendre plus mais donc je
disais que une bonne idée ce sera en
fait d'essayer de voir des partis
classiques ou faire des parties
anciennes joué par les meilleurs joueurs
sur sur la variante comprendre les plans
les schémas des choses comme ça et puis
après petit à petit commencé à raffiner
bas à prendre cette théorie voir comment
ça évolue à travers l'histoire est une
manière plus moderne qu'est ce qui se
passe est donc là didon je commence la
première étape dans l'article donc
disons qu'on veut jouer le coup un b3
bon tu prennes exemples comme ça
pourquoi pas et donc b3 kouba s'appelle
en ouverture à l'art scène où lars and
the beach pourquoi parce que justement
cette énigme the beach qui était un des
premiers for the arts à l'employé puis
larsen
quelques décennies plus tard et il a
donc récemment les meilleurs joueurs
qu'ils jouent actuellement c'est plutôt
rapporte et joe baba même si nakamura
par exemple que le jeu de temps en temps
mais plutôt hambli de soi rapide donc
mais trois ans faites ce que je dis dans
l'article 5 ou
deux hyper moderne dans la proche est il
est donc ce matin le fonds chantiers
d'eau et qu'ils fassent action sur le
centre dire qu'on le n'occupe pas le
centre avec nos pions mais on va le
contrôler à distance
voilà donc donc voila et donc je voulais
montrer une partie un sujet dont qui
sera relié à l'article et voilà donc ces
deux parties entre nîmes dovic et où ces
élites d'elle turcot stéphane aude sont
de beaux présents
j'imagine ce genre italien est ok donc
newsweek jeu qu'on sait par cas les f3
ça va pas changer grand chose puisque ce
soir des 5 il a joué de b3 à ce moment
là et donc qu'ils soient concentrés
c'est dans l'article c'est 5 donc qui
est qui est comment dire
le le voilà le set-up schéma entre
guillemets auquel je m'intéresse ok je
m'intéresse ici donc les noirs font
descendre ses cinq bien sûr il y en a il
ya beaucoup d'autres manières de
de jouer par exemple en fait évidemment
sur b3 premier coup alors que cinq
autres trucs mais donc voilà ok vous b2
christie 6 alors plus tard il ya une
partie assez célèbre en fait dans cette
position entre entre fisher et
petrossian je pense dans 70 71 peut-être
et et fisher avait joué avec m6 est en
fait soit disant du coup c'était pas le
bonheur de coûts pour les blancs d'être
lequel il rêve 3 et c'était mieux de de
plus tôt donc du coup joué les trois
premiers coups des cinq maisons four b2
ça ils trois absences gardera peut-être
l'option de faire un théâtre pour mieux
contrôler le centre mais je dois dire
que ok ça c'est venu plus tard déjà bon
c'est pas le problème
et de deux en fait lui reste seulement
malgré tout c'est pas si claires
notamment avec ce coup là un peu
provocateur mon intéressant
il est des blancs fait c'est que si les
noirs vaunage 5
on aura aux 4 est ok pas mal parce qu'on
fait pression là-dessus le pion va
devoir va soit prendre soin pousser et
du conte suite le flou viendra en c4 il
sera plutôt bien placé donc même ça
c'est pas ce pas clair quoi mais meybon
fo qui recueille 6 6 2 3 6 et 6 foulée 5
dans l'article on a vu plein de partis
là-dessus et donc l orge dalle refuse de
se faire échanger en c6 et se faire
doubler les pions parce que comme on l'a
dit enfin quand derrière cette structure
la haye français si c'est donc un b
prend le pion c5 va être difficile à
défendre notamment avec la main notre
pays ces trois cavaliers à 4 et
éventuellement fois trois ans suit donc
pour les noirs flow gic de défendre
petit râteau 6 très bien détroit flo7
calé deux rocs et francis
faut prendre voilà il semble pas les
pions équivalent de 5 donc ça c'est une
pression démesurée plusieurs fois et
j'ai montré deux autres partis dans
cette position où trois lunes où il ya
eu foule est vite joué ici par bobine
stein une autre ou où ça a été cuite 17
le coup joué par les noirs et et qu'est
ce jeu et voilà elad entre la partie sur
clio 5 les dents on fait pour ces huit
voire pourquoi pas sa place la tour ce
pas trop mal sur calais français si
souffert tout reprendre ok f4 jouer donc
jour même schéma donc on renforce le la
case ou 5 f 4 on peut aussi
éventuellement utiliser la tour pour
venir attaquer à l'e3 et pourquoi pas un
jour aussi pourquoi pas faire f 5
ok alors qu'elle évite a été jouée par
les noirs pourquoi pas ça va c'est le
meilleur ils vont peut-être remettre le
fou ici quatre pas mal est donc très
souvent on voit toujours cette manière
de jouer
denise rietsch qui est revenue plusieurs
fois dont il est parti c'est il met
volontiers sépulture case blanche
donc ça marche bien avec le foot cases
noires qui maintient les cases noires et
ses pions la surface blanche donc ça
fait une double by square demi ensemble
quoi alors qu' on prend je pense c'est
une faute
enfin très coûteux parce que la
structure après ça c'est toujours un peu
nu pour les blancs donc et noir
j'imagine c'était plus logique je veux
être comme des cinq pour essayer de le
c4 ou quoi ensuite concédé contre joël
dame mais ont varié la partie puis on
prend tout comprendre ils ont gardé une
cavale et investissent donc pour
attaquer ou 4
il a défendu et dames 2 alors
éventuellement les blancs a pu prendre
part le tour prend où ils ont pris tout
le blé les pions et puis comme dame de
maintenant donc ce qui a évité que après
tour des six siècles ou à je me sens
frais jusqu'à et cecab dessus
et donc ensuite l'idée et l'entrée de
forme de fer à 4 mètres l'occasion c4 et
on place bien les pièces et je pense que
oui on débuts au petit avantage pas
mesdames de jouer comme ses sept tours à
d un port sd 8 à 4 très bien des 6 et
continue donc son idée des pions sur
case blanche et il lance un peu
l'attaqué contre bâle est le roi si on
prend un pion prend feu et fuite ok ce
manque là cela un coup classique seront
tournés avec le roi kg 4 alors c'est pas
le coup kg car en soi qui est classique
mais c'est d'échanger lecavalier 6 donc
lequel existe toujours c'est ce qu'a dit
qu'ils font pas mal le roi et juri part
ça crée des brèches prise dame prend
donc là il ya une menace directe pour
les blancs ça te faire [ __ ] angers 7
au prochain coup et surtout prend ou
fera f6 donc il aurait fallu elysées un
fou noir ici et les blancs font m6 et il
y aura peut être défense comme dans le
projet 7 donc ça les noirs ils le voient
ils font rage suite ok très bien
m6 g6 donc vais voir ça un peu à
l'étroit mais ça tient pas trop mal ou
qui avait laissé quatre au québec prise
prises tous vos huit hockey laisse place
à une colonne là un petit coussin pas
fou le 5
alors pendant plus râleurs faut 5 way
est donc tout reprend pas possible si on
reprend pas possible parce qu'en fait
ils dament jetteront est sympa et le
clouage donc on gagnera une qualité et
clément donc de ses huit hockey prise
prise et est donc cette finale
donc certes aideront la paire de fumay
garde-fous passive en fait quelque part
on voit le faux effectifs et de pas
grand chose donc pas mal n'est que les
blancs dans la tour qui contrôlent qu
elle ouverte
le roi un peu à l'étroit à griffer h4
pour éventuellement peut-être un jour
vouloir mettre dans des réseaux je sais
pas donc les normes bloqué au f4 non m
libert la caisse de 5 pour lequel elle
est franche sept mois de mai donc tirer
10 5e 8 pour défendre f7 mais bon voilà
les morceaux je suis assez étriqués et
c4 fixe fixé structure pas même sa faux
âge 6 avril a fait bouger 5 j'aime bien
puisque comme ça c est noir venait à
prendre enfin je prends et un nouveau le
roi sera une sorte de sarcophage de
temps bloqués et les blancs pourrait
tranquillement vouloir améliorer la
position augmenter le roi peut être
rentré peut-être à vous faire j'ai
quatre aussi pour comme je disais mètres
lors un peu dans des réseaux et tours à
chaque étranger 4 etc
ouais donc logiquement être bonheur de
pas trop prendre et sont repartis
barrois f2 donc là quand c'est comme ça
très bien ce qui fait du bio vie qu il
améliore sa position en fait il n'est
pas pressé pour trois à six tours
détroit jouer ok on va bien comprendre
pourquoi en fait il veut jouer qui avait
17 et pour l'instant ça marche très très
mal évidemment parce qu'il y aurait il y
aurait autour des luttes il ya un
clouage donc en retour des 3 et rend le
caïd est cette possible retour à huit a
été joué mon bac et 17 attaques donc le
pion b6 et l'a donc avec les marées vie
d'avant il faut pas prendre enfin le
problème d'opposition c'est que en fait
la tour sa septième excellente l avenir
ici en baisse est notamment attaqué le
pion et si les noirs faisait une sorte
de défense pour sais rien moi sur la sur
la sixième en rangée dans le genre de
cas de figure ces dosettes stream strati
femme ça va pas du tout parce qu'ils ont
fait tomber vite et on cloue le choix et
fuite et on veut jouer fois justice
ensuite il ya juste pas de défense qui
ont racheté à thurey ton grand fou donc
donc voilà alors que les dix-sept il a
fait b5 pas mal joué à bab kébé six
attaques la tour qui bouge qui est des
cinq
alors il ya eu les sarthois des huit
jurés qui a laissé cette proposé change
des tours et attaque bessin au passage
est en fait jusqu'à présent la partie a
été très bien très très bien mener la
part de nîmes the beach est juste là il
prend une mauvaise décision je pense il
jouait à mediaset
donc ce qui semble quand même assez
intéressant parce qu'on va échanger tout
le fruit fuite et ce qui paraît clair ce
qu'on va prendre ce pion et puis on va
pousser le roi va soutenir le pion est
normalement les normes moi ça qui fait
le fou dessus on va gagner mais on va
voir quand vous faites une bonne défense
et du coup on fait le mieux c'est de
faire [ __ ]
pour simplement prendre ce pion est
valorisée ensuite le plombier voilà c
est l histoire de fous de couleurs
opposées aussi et c'était un air plus
propre pour l'emporter parce qu'en fait
d'avoir kallio cette prise prise là il
ya un très bon coup d'ailleurs qui a été
jouée par par le joueur italien et pts 6
alors c'est quoi l'idée l'idée c'est que
sur [ __ ] ordre ils veulent faire bref
cette bombe à sa tête le fou mais
surtout ça défend la caisse de promotion
et surtout g5
du coup le fou 17 n'a plus à rester ici
à défendre pour 8
il peut faire échec maintenant les
bombes et son envie de prendre parce
qu'il faut prendre les trois ça fait
juste nul en gros en fait pas le normand
rien à faire on peut mettre l'europe en
piscine et ensuite on mettra le feu sur
cette diagonale et on bouge pas foulard
à pirna temps comme ça il va rien se
passer
en fait c'est toujours une très bonne
méthode de défense avec les fous
toujours opposé le roi s'occupe du tout
passé il se méprendre sur la couleur où
ils y passent pas à tania pas
atteignables kouakou leur opposer au
foie de vars et on met nos pions sur la
couleur notre fou et le fou fait le job
de l'autre côté donc chacun fait son
truc et il ya juste un moyen pour les
ventes progresser donc sur fotsis bien
sûr reprend ses cinq noms dont il
faudrait plutôt plutôt faire
on a ces trois là sont vraiment fait les
marais food et 5 bon disons attaque g2
et g3 et ils font plus rien 12h30 je
passe et le truc
en fait on a ça le pion c5 et le fou des
cinq qui font barrière
donc en fait les bleus ne passent pas
s'il vient d'attaquer ce options on
prend et c'est la même histoire que je
raconte est en fait on ne mène le roi
sur les dames on peut se mettre en
baisse est donc ça va bloquer le pion il
va rien se passer bougera pas et puis
notre fou bon ajout défendre g6 avec
vous très important sur 7 des gones a
levé 1
et puis plus de progrès possible
donc en fait les blancs on peut pas
faire feu 3 mais quoi qu'il fasse en
fait il se passera le roi ces trois
attachés à la défense de tomber 3 le fou
d'attaché l'absurde défense de kew ça tu
es et voilà donc et fils d'excellentes
tentative est ok donc in the beach se
réalise ça il retire son fou dit lui
faut aussi ces chèques
donc il fait le fameux truc et il n'y a
pas eu en france et 5 passes qu'il y
aurait à voir éclater
et ben voilà on est un truc je suis là
donc on a plutôt le bureau s'attend
guère d'options plus loin possible mais
une nouvelle fois en fait le roi va
venir s'y passait par là est ok et quoi
faire donc
donc ça va être nul ok donc sur ces
trois différences et 3 mai regrette
cette france et 5 donc à un ton plus
lincou normal et bien je parle par des
noirs cg 5 pour échanger plus d'options
possibles pour pour annuler il ya eu g3
jouer et là et north sont un peu
embrouillé en fait cercle ar pour
essayer de faire nul en fait il fallait
réduire le nombre d'options dont on
comprend mais en plus on a vu la tension
et on envoyait le plus bref on fait et
ça c'est important
c'est pour dévier ce fou
qui pour l'instant défend là et du coup
il va pas pour tout faire par an s'il
est bon doublé 4
on envoie f4 donc l'illustration simple
c'est que soient pas en bessin confessa
et cybit cissé ben fèves deux parties
pour faire d'abord on fait d'avoir
fraudé 5 et et on fera avec nous au coup
d'après voilà ce qu'ils veulent
là il y avait donc des noirs qui gagne
enfin des quatre seraient distribués sur
une faute mais je sais pas quoi détroit
je sais pas quel coût ok on peut juste
attendre donc là les blancs font rien
ils se passe rien à entendre on tourne
en rond et puis un jour jours sinon on
fait 2 foucras on reprend et pour vous
disais le roi n'a plus qu'à venir par
ici le pire ne renoncera jamais et le
fou croient toujours dur à défendre h56
a besoin ok donc ça c'était sûrement sur
mon dieu en fait mais il a way il ne
peut tergiverser
alors peut-être qu'il va encore le moyen
de faire nul mais disons-le à l'eiblen
améliore le sable leurs positions et
surtout en fait il s un thème hyper
important il fait fuji 6 et là bas vous
mettre en pause pour chercher mes temps
pose de votre côté pour chercher comment
l'emporté avec les blancs voilà bah
écoute et j'espère vos amis vous avez
trouvé
et l'idée si j'ai quatre excellents en
fait l'idée c'est de se créer un pion h
passées et nas et c'est imparable en
fait la soie les blancs vont prendre
soin et noir prennent avant et de toi
son pouce et là en fait avec deux pions
aussi éloigner le fou peut pas défendre
les deux vivent 5 6 4 17
il ya eu abandon savons pas ce que vont
bien sûr flambé cette menace at il une
âme charisme donc moi je trouve la
partie pas mal bien construite
je salue très pas mal les idées les et
qu'on a déjà vu donc en gros
c'est pas spécialement pour vous faire
jouer b trop premier coup en fait
l'article été vu sur une méthodologie
montré bon là j'ai expliqué la partie un
peu ce que yahvé petite finale vous leur
posez d'autres trucs cool meiway est
plutôt une méthodologie est donc en gros
là vous seriez prêt pour jouer contre ce
jardin de chez moi donc des cinq ses
cinq premiers noirs mais le reste du
boulot alors peut-être fred autre
article dessus on verra si ça vous plait
ou quoi les retours mais en gros
forestier question oui mais maintenant
il faut que je sois prêt aussi sur
l'adversaire ne joue pas c'est ça que
mes jours sans infliger quatre coins des
coûts par exemple d un autre schéma
et puis ensuite être prêt sur aube est
3e 5
les héros y foulée deux bombes alors
soit il joue avec des six sous et jouets
qui haïssez 6 le 3 et ils sont ils
prennent le centre soit ils ont pas
envie fonds cai et 6 brisera pas envie
parce que sur des cinq ils sont sujets
aux clouage et donc il ya tout de suite
une pression sur le centre met donc les
noirs sont riches gagnent et si si si ou
alors aussi ya pas mal de joueurs
alors mme fisher c'était son cas qui
jouait en fait plutôt des des sissi et
l'inversé dijon et ses quatre enfants
ce genre de trucs il a fait des belles
parties il est battu ou l'oeuf anderson
une partie célèbre dessus et les battues
aussi peut-être tout comme un coffre
voilà tout c'était pas des saints gars
qui jouent cette d'abord ou quoi mais
toute façon c'était ce genre structure
mais voilà donc si complètement un autre
type de position mais après une fois
qu'on a ce bagage comme connaît les
trucs qu'on peut on peut s'y lancer quoi
donc et si en pratique et puis aussi
regarder un peu plus en détail la
théorie mais voilà donc c'est un peu
long pour cette démarche là donc
j'espère toutefois que la vidéo zap lu
l'article aussi vous allez retrouver en
lien sous la vidéo
et puis bah n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
aussi donc à la chaîne de check point
comme puisqu'ils apparel de contenu donc
moi je fais souvent des vidéos donc la
série sur les joueurs français des
vidéos ci en relation avec les articles
et puis aussi kevin qui
il fait des des parties rapides donc
donc voila vous auriez les notifications
extra je pense que toute bonne idée quoi
voilà nous savons donc je vous souhaite
une bonne journée de mode sans relâche
pas et elle vous regarde à ça et puis à
très bientôt quoi ciao ciao